[Music]
you know what this overused music means
it's update time in the world of
fortnite battle royale
if you're new around these parts this is
a series which breaks down
all the map changes on the island to
find out the secrets you should know
even if it's only a blade of grass out
of place so
sit your butt down for 10 minutes day
walkers slap code adamarrow in the store
to keep this series going
and let's do this
[Music]
let's start with the bromance these two
henchmen
found each other last week and even
though they represented different sides
ghost and shadow they built a friendship
around their love of sick dance moves
last week it was at a lonely gas station
in the middle of nowhere
but this week they have moved into the
hotel at lazy lake
you can find them having a pool party
it's touching stuff they go enjoy a
barbecue together in the sunshine
before wolfing down a pizza they take
the party indoors and try out a little
just dance on the nintendo wii
before once again having a dance-off
playing with each other's balls
and finally a crescendo like no other
they put on a mini concert these guys
aren't worried about sweats we can all
learn a few things from these guys
in fact hang on it's time to name the
bros i'm thinking vinnie and steve but
what do you think what should we name
the brothers from other mothers
oh while we're here at lazy lake one of
the strangest things we didn't get to
talk about last time
was something really bizarre each week i
drop here to see if the diorama inside
the no swept building
is here yet and each week it's a no but
the real story here is right across the
street
at house number one in fact it's both
houses here
have you spotted the difference they
have been rotated and faced away from
the roadside
in terms of gameplay the biggest thing
to note is the tunnel which connected
both houses became blocked
there was no way through the really
strange thing on the street level is
that the garages are impossible to reach
by a vehicle
so my ocd kicked in and i couldn't
handle it anymore so i made this wrong
into a right
there much better they now have a
functioning garage well this week
look again because the houses have
changed once more
the garages are now redesigned and a
little bit more accessible from the
front
and even the lost tunnel connecting the
two houses that is now back again
so gg developer who noticed this issue
and thanks for putting it right
my ocd thanks you so we're at lazy lake
let's go a little bit further south
hut watch baby the journey of this
construction is long
and hard and each week i perch upon it
in the hopes that it grows
and this week things have improved yet
again take a look at it there's a second
archway in place
and get this in your eye holes a window
a legit window on hut watch
this building is one step closer to
perfection
did you know it's been two years since
the original hot watch was founded
do you feel old yet yeah me too the road
above is now
almost clear it's getting closer i have
a horrible feeling though that that is
going to drop
down and smash hut watch anxious times
ahead
i need your help with something now
while looking around the map for micro
changes
i spotted this is this new
on closer inspection it's like a giant
seat
maybe this is a call back to the chair
in chapter one or maybe it's always been
here and i'm just not as aware as matt
changes as i thought i was
oh the shame anyway who needs a seat
this big how big is galactus
speaking of galactus he's still in the
sky and two weeks ago it got a little
bit bigger
therefore a little bit closer to us
[Music]
as always i checked up on our lord and
savior graeme the gnome
he's fine by the way and that led me to
hunt down the guy peddling super slurp
juice last week
if you remember rightly we saw him
explode
and presumed he was deaded
but oh no no he has rebuilt himself
and i mean literally he can now be found
in the old ghost building underneath the
heroes park new poi down in the basement
check out this domain first though look
at his face
he's now half robot he's rebuilt himself
using android technology
and is now hell bent on taking down all
the gnomes
he's like a genome two-face down here
you can see his plan taking shape
rigging up slurp juice to explode and
tricking unassuming gnomes into trying
the super slurp juice
when in fact he intends to blow them up
at each of the locations on the map here
there are five rigged barrels and your
job in game is to disarm them all for xp
before any more of our brothers and
sisters are tricked
i decided to take action and eradicated
this troublesome gnome
but i'm sure he'll be back next week and
i think i know how he's going to do this
look on the ground by his feet these
little robots
well first they're cute little buggers
but secondly
what are these cretins for i'd love to
see your predictions here
the future of his evil plans this is
also your last chance to suggest a name
for this villain
so far the winning name is sherlock
gnomes but now he's a madman and half
android
i thought we'd wait a little longer to
name him so i'll be in the comments
again
looking for suggestions i'll update you
next time we meet up
around the map it looks like the gnomes
are onto this evil plan
and are going full banksy on his posters
and advertisements
they are defacing any positive media
around this
there are also genomes spreading the
word too but are they here to help
or are they part of the plan to
terminate the genome population
either way this is another great subplot
isn't it from the fortnite devs
long may it whoa continue whoa
whoa hold on a sec i'm reading this all
wrong there are in fact
two gnomes a good one and a bad one the
good one's blue the bad one is red
how could i not see this before and the
bad one wants to see everyone burn
but he actually isn't a gnome i think i
know who's behind this
nick fury he's back to rid the world of
genomes using
cyborg tech hit me with your predictions
what's going down here
remember when the trask poi appeared on
the map and we all tried to figure out
who was on board that transport
well this week it has been totally
ripped apart and the mutant
has escaped judging by the claw max this
is wolverine who is now in the game
have you found him yet logan is prowling
the forest area
and is looking for some action i tried
to take him down
and failed many times if you have bested
weapon x himself
please tell us how oh in fact let's take
a moment to look how cool the model
is wolverine looks awesome and the
visual sound effects when he brings out
his claws
is just so epic but legend has it he is
killable
i feel a myth chaser episode coming on
subtly a new star has appeared over by
holly hedges
it sprang up overnight and by the looks
of it
it's nothing near finished just yet
inside there is so much more to do
there are functioning urinals i know
that's the most important thing
but the walls need to be painted carpets
need to be put down there's no
decorations there's no direction as into
what this will actually be
so once again i ask you what will the
store become
i'll be sure to keep recording the
changes each day and piece them all
together in our next meetup
maybe this will be the new halloween
store and maybe it will move away from
retail row
or it could be for another crossover are
there any marvel superheroes that live
at a store
maybe not right now it looks like it's a
unique spot so changes are incoming and
hopefully
it will be a big update next time
something i neglected to bring up last
time last month i showed you this
basketball court at swetty sands
and a very strange bucket at one end it
was so damn tall
i quested you guys to score a basket in
there and you locked didn't disappoint
check out this shot from rs technology
loving the og hot watch in there too i
wanted to showcase more shots but i need
youtube links rather than twitter videos
for this to work
anyway thank you those people who sent
me their awesome shots oh there is one
last thing of note before we go up
at stark industries firstly there is a
strange currency in game
in which the garage part doesn't load in
at all this is likely for another update
coming next week
and i think i know how go to the science
area where we usually find iron man and
all his armor
and you'll see the white board with
designs upon it
these are the blueprints for the new and
improved battle bus
whether this is for the birthday
celebrations in game or maybe for the
end of season event
either way the battle bus is going to
change and i cannot wait
so there we have it week five season
four chapter two is in the book so what
a great update
please let me know what i missed and
i'll be sure to add them next time
on screen now are a few of the legends
who used code adamaru in the store over
the last few weeks
i'm over a week behind on dms again i'm
sorry about that
i'll be trying my best to reply to
everyone later this week in time for the
next episode
i'm adam from playstation grenade you're
awesome and i'll see you next time
[Music]
me